c'est une assez vieilles constante dans notre
pays qu'à un moment donné une partie de la
population parce qu'elle sent effectivement que
nous sommes dans une situation compliquée se
disent finalement le dernier recours c'est
l'armée et oui après tout pourquoi pas que
je me souviens qu'il ya déjà quelques quelques
dizaines d'années il y avait dans les journaux
des tribunes disant si ça continue il faudra
y envoyer l'armée une fois qu'on a dit ça est
ce que finalement mis au pied du mur et voyant
la réalité d'une intervention militaire et la
totalité de ceux qui ont répondu positivement à
ce sondage serait heureux du résultat j'en suis
absolument pas persuadé parce qu'encore une fois
ce qui manque dans tout cela c'est de dire qu'on
n'a pas épuisé toutes les voies de recours on n'a
pas épuisé toutes les voies de recours parce que
le politique peut se saisir davantage se saisir
mieux de la situation parce qu'il ya quand même
la démocratie qui permet d'exprimer un vote
parce qu'on a parlé tout à l'heure du volet
policier de la répression des incivilités la
délinquance paye également les questions du
volet judiciaire sur lequel il ya me semble-t-il
beaucoup de discussions à avoir donc je crois
qu'il faut prendre de ce sondage avec énormément
de pincettes ce putsch ne ne prend pas voilà parce
qu'on a aujourd'hui une société dans laquelle
on a les réseaux sociaux dans lesquels on à la
société civile etc l on a naturellement des des
contre-pouvoirs et il me semble véritablement que
les français n'accepteraient ces deux solutions
pour devrais je dire voyant le matin quand ils se
réveillent l'armée dans la rue il ne l'accepterai
véritablement qu'en cas de délitement absolue bien
au-delà de ce que nous connaissons ce qui
ne veut pas dire que la situation soit rôle